a prominent Democratic donor is accused
of running a drug den out of his
Southern California home Edie buck is
behind bars after his arrest overnight
two men have died in his West Hollywood
home from apparent overdoses since 2017
a third man survived an overdose last
week buck is well-known in Democratic
Party circles and has donated to Hillary
Clinton and other high-profile
candidates Niki batiste is following the
case Nikki what more do we know Anthony
a good morning we do know buck is
charged with a felony count of providing
methamphetamine to a 37 year old man who
then overdosed prosecutors call buck a
violent dangerous sexual predator who
mainly preys on men preys on men made
vulnerable by addiction and homelessness
Democratic mega donor Edie buck left his
Los Angeles home overnight in the back
of a police car the 65 year old is
charged with injecting drugs into a man
but police have I the powerful political
insider for more than two years it's
unfortunate that it's taken a third
overdose for the LA Sheriff's Department
to finally act we believe that that
third overt overdose could have been
avoided in January angry crowds gathered
outside bucks apartment after 55
year-old Timothy Dean was found dead of
an overdose in July 2017 26 year-old
Jamel Moore died there in similar
circumstances in court filings
prosecutors say buck used the bait of
narcotics money and shelter to lure
victims to his home we're in a position
of power buck manipulates his victims
into participating in his sexual
fetishes buck is an LGBTQ activist who
has donated tens of thousands of dollars
to high-profile Democratic candidates
including Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton bucks attorney
Seymour Amster this is not a situation
where mr. buck has caused the death this
is an in situation where mr. buck has
had
long time friends who unfortunately do
not handle their life well police say
they never had sufficient evidence to
arrest buck in the previous overdoses
prosecutors are recommending a bail to
be set at 4 million dollars if convicted
of supplying meth but could face a
maximum sentence of nearly six months in
prison very disturbing story thank you
very much and again